If you don't wanna be called Nazis,
stop doing. You're called an anti Semite more than a hostess table.
Yeah, and people will sit there and.
No, by me,
I never called you an anti Semite.
I mean, I'm not sitting here saying I'm a supporter of the Palestinians.
I'm used to it. Yeah,
well, I hope your Bieber doesn't go off.
The thing is, is that you just say I should die.
You should not. No.
Did you just say I should be killed?
No, I did not say that.
Hold on. Did you just say I should be killed on live TV?
Guys, let me.
Let me just stop. You said you heard my beep.
Of the Palestinian Hamas. Guys,
I said Palestinian. Are you.
I said, am I what?
Now? Tell Ryan that I apologize.
Ryan, that I apologize.
That I apologize. That I apologize.
Ryan. Ryan,
that is completely. That is completely.
That is completely.
Let's have first block say the Muslim guy should be blown up.
I apologize on TV. Don't say.
Don't say. Then I apologize.
You literally. I thought you said Hamas.
I apologize. You didn't think I said Hamas?
I said I supported Palestinian rights.
Yes, I did.
What's funny is Rudy Giuliani said this yesterday.
So you're a great guest to be here to defend Rudy Giuliani.
Give me one sec. Give me.
Give me one sec. And so at this point,
this is what We're in now.
This is America in 2024.
Forget the racism which I should die.
I didn't say that. You said,
what is Bieber mean? Don't give me your face.
Why did you say, with my Bieber?
What did you mean by the Bieber?
I said, what did you mean by the Bieber?
No, you didn't.
You said, I hope your Bieber doesn't go off.
At least have the guts to support your racist brother.